also insgesamt es war ganz ganz
interessant und es stimmt wirklich
im plural einerseits und bereich und und
andererseits auch ganz zufrieden für die
saaten wie die deutschen so spontan
reagieren können hätte wir das in
kamerun machen können dann werden wir
fühlten sich leute nicht so also würden
leute nicht so spontan reagieren
wir haben also ich kenne meine
landsleute und so spontan für sie nicht
reagieren und ich finde das ganz ganz
interessant und das thema eigentlich ist
gegen gegenstände umtauschen und mit
dieser aufgabe habe ich persönlich viel
gelernt dass man nicht nur alles mit
geld also wir müssen nicht immer alles
gibt drei stellen aber wichtiger ist
noch dass wir in ihnen in den händen
haben das ist auch richtig also wenn sie
kein geld haben dann bin ich immer dass
es ist alles ist unmöglich ich kann
nicht nein es gibt eine welt gestärkt
kann drucken sie in der linie was siegen
als gegenstand haben
und für so was sie miteinander zu
sprechen und ich bin mir
das kriegen werden passiert wohl also
insgesamt das war ein interessanter
interessanter tag mit einem
interessanten thema